[Music]
even though it's glamorous on television
in reality
not many people want to spend money on
that
dead people
[Music]
autopsied methodology is so important um
when it comes to to covert because
essentially it's a novel presentation
and i mean that's what autopsy published
built for it's it's built for
finding these things out and looking for
yourself and determining
how the virus is affecting different
organ systems the autopsy is the perfect
way to actually look at all body systems
to see how to make not just the lungs
which is the thing that one of those
people think about but in the
microvascular changes and how it kind of
leads to stroke and and venous
thrombosis and a whole spectrum of
things and you know when it comes to new
variants as well that's a question that
we have to ask ourselves that are the
new viral variants are they causing a
different pattern of microvascular
disease for example so that's why
autopsying these patients in my view is
is really important if you can do so
safely and i believe that we can
[Music]
the contribution of the actual viral
infection to their death might be
vastly different in some people the
coconut infection is only
one part of a number of
factors that just resulted in them dying
and and often it's not clear without an
autopsy and what is the primary
operative factor in some of those you
know more subtle cases
[Music]
i think some of the misconceptions are
that we can always come up with a court
of death straight away and everything
kind of happens quickly and that
everything is black and white there's
lots of tests that need to be done and
you need to consider the balance of all
of those things and sometimes you might
not be able to say
what the very precise thing that caused
that person's death is i think probably
one of the other misconceptions is that
we can always determine a cause of death
we have a category of autopsies which
the cause of death will be undetermined
after we've done extensive
investigations
the covert autopsies that we've done
here won't take an hour
obviously um we're sort of wearing some
cool ppe and bits and pieces sometimes
that just makes things take a wee bit
longer
but the autopsy bit of itself you know
that's only the first part really the
histology reporting for example the work
that's been done in the micro lab to
sort of confirm the infection and
whether we can not just identify the
virus in nasopharyngeal swab but also in
lung tissue and other specimens that
kind of hour is only kind of the tip of
the iceberg really there's lots of other
things that need to be done before the
whole thing's complete
you